please welcome emma corn and josh
o'connor
[Applause]
[Music]
i love seeing how different you are in
real life isn't hair makeup wardrobe
just
everything it's the best honestly
it is i mean it's so exciting for us to
see you guys like this you know and when
i'm doing my thing it's like
i can see what you really look like and
then i have to say also i'm immediately
transported the second i'm in
um and i too
as an actor just it's like it changes
your body language when you put on
the clothes and everybody's marveling at
these side by sides of how
impeccably right that you've got it
and it does make a huge difference
because then everybody
can sort of fall into the history
of you know i mean i i really don't know
how else to explain it other than
this was at the center of all of our
universes and i do want to share
something with you
um okay we probably have a screenshot of
it but this is
actually here i keep this with me at the
studio there is me
presenting the et doll to princess diana
um when i was seven years old in 1982 at
the world premiere of e.t
and that's very sweet and uh
it it was a moment that i will never
forget and i keep the picture nearby
because
i really was the girl you know amongst
millions of other girls who grew up with
princess diana
and i mean you know emma what was it
like
to get into her i i i you're so
amazing as her and i just want to say
that the first scene you guys have
together to me was so poetically
choreographed and with all the history
that we know
about you know charles and diana to set
the stage in this
very coquettish eyeball
mysterious shakespearean way
was really amazing did you like the
introduction of these characters
yeah i really did i think you've kind of
hit the nail on the head there
by saying it sort of shakespearean
because
there's such a historical romance i
suppose associated with that kind of
depiction
of two characters meeting that almost
transcends
all kind of reality and i guess it kind
of goes hand in hand with the whole
fairy tale
thing that they have going on in the
beginning of the series
um i thought it was a really beautiful
way of doing their introduction
yeah i agree yeah i suppose
it just it's like we wanted
more going into it and then that scene
set us up for just wanting more and more
and more
um josh i i must say that you're
acting with your eyes and your body
language i
also noticed that first of all when
actors
do internal i'm sorry but it's usually
snoozy and boring i'm like i hope you're
having fun because i'm not watching it
because you're a journal
and i need something you do internal so
well
i was so gripped with your eyes and your
shoulders you could not say anything in
an entire scene and i was riveted
and i also loved how i felt like
as a viewer i thought i saw your body
language really changed when you were
with
emma um like you were more confident and
more of a cad
and like your demeanor changed was that
conscientious because i totally picked
that up as a viewer
um thank you yeah i suppose i think we
did lots of work on
the kind of physicality of these
characters i think
you can tell so much um with
sort of body language and as you know
and i think
um particularly with charles is kind of
very early on we sort of picked up on
this
sort of stoop that he has and the way he
kind of leans his neck out and
um we worked with polly bennett he's a
brilliant movement coach and we we kind
of
both emma and i were keen to find sort
of why they
stand like that or um where that body
language
uh is rooted from and so
you know as we went through the series
we had this sort of like ongoing joke
about
just how far charles does stoop and that
as the pressure of the world gets more
he just sort of ends up
like a hunchback really i mean it's
quite it's quite intense
and you in your own life uh i heard a
story about a little date where
you showed up it wasn't so smooth
yeah i mean this is quite a long time
ago drew so let's just
start with that way in the rearview
mirror yeah just like i said this isn't
a recent occurrence
but i yeah i did take um i was uh
maybe like 13 14 and i did take a girl
it was on a double date and my mum had
given me
not very much uh money so i only had
enough money to take us to the cinema
and we went to the cinema and then it
was easter and afterwards
the other guy was like let's go and get
these girls some eggs
like chocolate eggs and we went to the
uh
chocolate shop and he got this beautiful
egg
with the girl's name sort of printed you
know with like
beautiful chocolate writing and i
got a small egg and then realized i had
no money and so she had to buy her own
which was
um less than brilliant you know you
could just tell her listen i'm going to
be playing
prince charles in my future so don't
worry
about the size of the egg um emma
i loved a detail before we go that you
said
when i don't know who you were saying
this with but that when you felt the
nerves of all the attention being diana
and all of that energy
that you should channel it into the
performance who do you have that
conversation with
so that's um a conversation i had with
ben caron one of the directors
um just after i got the part actually
and i remember him
sitting me down and saying you know your
life's going to change a lot and
any time you feel overwhelmed or nervous
or there are people taking photographs
of you
or you end up in the news use it because
it's a completely parallel experience
that you're having
and really it did really come really
come in handy yeah i remember one day we
were filming
in london on the street and the scene
was
me being chased by paparazzi as young
diana
and then behind the supporting actors
who were playing with paparazzi were
actual paparazzi
who were there for me and it was such a
weird
like yeah colliding of worlds but
actually weirdly useful
well i think that's a a very smart
direction and you took it so well and
you're honoring these
people who we've grown up with that are
such icons in this world
and doing them such justice and we
love it and i think you guys are
incredible and i was so thrilled
that you would come on the show today
thank you emma and josh season 4 of the
crown is out now
everybody knows it everybody's watching
it it's the talk of everything thank you
[Music]